hey guys and welcome back to steampunks
my name is Jess I'm ed and you're tuned
in to the show where we run through all
of the releases that have come through
on Steam over the past week and tell you
what are the good ones you should keep
an eye out for ed what did you have this
week okay first up this week is a game
called laser League this is a futuristic
sports game from the studio that brought
you the skateboarding game Ollie ollie
so this is a two on two or three on
three scenario where you're running
around an arena which has a moving laser
fields that can be activated by anodes
by sort of either team and once you
activate a node you can actually run
through your own colored laser fields
and you get creamed if you run into an
opponent's laser field so once you
activate one of these days they'll
expire after a while and so the whole
game is sort of a balance between
grabbing the nodes as they appear in
disappear and keeping control of the map
so HBO has a different layout at
different nodes that do different things
in what kind of stuff so your goal in
the laser League is to be the last team
standing so first of all you can run to
the edge of a map and you'll appear on
the other side so that makes it possible
to escape really really dire situations
as well as set up sneak attacks by
keeping an eye on the other side and
once someone gets down they can easily
be revived if a teammate just touched
the icon they leave on the floor and
then you can pick like different classes
with different abilities so each of the
class has one unique skill and they're a
couple of modifiers that slightly alters
that skills behavior so you can choose
classes like the hunter which is
basically like an insta-kill - strike a
charger who is non-lethal but knocks
people away and then there are more
interesting and indirect classes like
the shocker you can just stun other
players and sort of mixing the collapse
on the floor unable to move for a while
then there also powers that pop up on
the field and can drastically change the
field if they're activated but these
sort of behaviors like swapping all the
nodes to the opposite color or say
splitting up solid laser walls so it's
not always advantageous to activate one
of you in the lead so laser lake is
coming out on Xbox one and ps4 the same
time as PC and they've said they're
working on cross play but whether that's
gonna be enough off the water something
will just kind of have to wait and see
but as it stands if you have four
friends and you just want like a really
really fast one and like hilarious party
game
competitive party game laser League is
15 bucks only
[Applause]
alright well that game looks really fun
I also had quite a lot of fun playing a
huge game this week which is why this
week I'll just be talking about the one
game I'm about six hours into pillars of
eternity two dead fire it does carry on
from the end of the first game which
means there's a lot of nice little
Easter eggs and revisiting characters in
there for people who played the first
game but it's also a pretty good entry
point for those who didn't on that point
you can import a history of your
decisions in the first game or you can
just create a new one so your impetus is
that you're the captain of a ship
chasing a towering God across the Dead
Fire archipelago and you can help all
hurt people you encounter as you go this
game is a ton of fun it's made by
obsidian who are responsible for one of
my favorite RPGs of all time now it's
the other public - and I really don't
think they've let anybody down with this
one they are really good storytellers
and this is a great story
pillars of eternity - is absolutely
charming and crazy robust it will put
some people off in that it's incredibly
complex everything from the combat to
the way you design your characters and
the RPG elements demands a lot of
attention and patience but if you're
willing to put that in and if you love
RPGs this one has a lot to give so apart
from the traditional isometric
traversing of towns and such there's a
really nice overworld map it's totally
worth exploring and it rewards you for
exploring there are a ton of magical
place names and gods and races and
things that happened that I mentioned
early on but the game's pretty smart
about ensuring that all those terms can
be hovered over for an explanation
so combat is not turn-based although you
will be pausing it all the time so you
can issue commands and tell people where
they need to be there is also party AI
which is on by default so there's the
opportunity to tell the party AI exactly
what skills you want it to prioritize
when you want it to cast certain spells
when you want it to do this or engage or
how to engage and you can take on as
much or as little of this as you want to
there's a variety of difficulty settings
ranging from story mode where
everything's going to be a priest all
the way to brutally tricky ship combat
is a huge part of this game as you're
venturing through the archipelago
half the time you're actually on your
ship and managing your ship and your
crewmates and such combat on the high
seas is delivered in scripted sequences
and it's turn-based whether you're
exploring on your boats or on the land
you'll occasionally encounter scripted
events where you make choices based on
your stats or morals these include your
party stats not just the stats of the
character you create in the beginning so
it's a good idea to balance those and
it's really interesting to see how you
can engage with things based on choices
you've made as you level one thing I
really love about this game is that
everything you say to anybody changes
what kind of person you are so this
whole game is very heavily drawing from
dandy and there is something in your
character sheet that tells you how kind
you are how honest you are benevolent
how nasty so this game is fifty dollars
which is a lot but the characters are
really vibrant and well voiced the
combat on land and ships is way more
interesting than your isometric
hack-and-slash games and the story is
really well paced so you want to keep
going back but you don't feel rushed to
take one more step on your journey or
just go off and do something else
sometimes the feelings they just come
tumblin right out of me gods darn it
alright you like worthy games well
connects game I'm gonna talk about is
very wordy as well but it's Japanese if
this is a visual novel called steins
gate zero I'm sure a lot of you know
what a visual novel is but if you don't
it's a style of narrative adventure game
which has a huge focus on characters and
story science gate is a very very
popular series and it's up there with
zero time dilemma and dagger and romper
and the reason why all these guys are
popular is because they all have really
really complex stories full of big
twists reveals and really mindfuck story
points they're steins gate zero is
actually a sequel to the original
science gate and it's got a big focus on
science and technology as it deals with
concepts of time travel the morals of AI
and how the brain and memory works and
it basically gives a version of time
travel whereby there is sort of like
multiple variations on a timeline that
exists but there's only one running at a
certain time until another one he's
active
is bought into the main timeline the
protagonist you play has the ability to
swap the active timeline by sending text
as a sequel I actually think it's fine
to jump straight into this one if you
missed the first one one of the reasons
is that the writing is very slow very
explanatory and they tend to retread
over the same points again and again
yeah and because this is a story that
deals with time-travel you're actually
experiencing events from a new beginning
anyway science gate it's also really
good at handling obscure fictional terms
in glossary much like you were saying
with colors of eternity so when they
juice for the first time they
highlighted and you can pop into sort of
a glossary for a very short very easily
digestible explanation and what might
potentially be a new concept to you but
I can tell you from experience with a
lot of these types of games that
sticking with them is worth it because
the the text eventually does draw you
put you deep into the characters and the
events happening and that really helps
because when [ __ ] starts to go down it
really really hits you signs get zero on
its own is 35 bucks and bundled with the
original stands gate it is 60 bucks so
it sounds like you did a lot of reading
I didn't do a lot of reading and I saw
you playing another game this week where
you did a lot of dying I didn't let him
dying I did a lot of dying and I did a
lot of buildings yeah in Conan exiles
it's a third-person survival game
sitting the Conan the Barbarian universe
this is the first time I've played it
it's been the only access for a while
and man this game is freaking huge I had
no idea how huge this game was this is
very much a granular survival game with
a huge focus on crafting and combat and
exploration the gist is that you've been
exiled you're an exile Conan comes and
cuts you down off a cross and it's up to
you to survive in this huge land along
with other exiles so you have to worry
about things like certain go temperature
health stamina and stop getting yourself
out with more advanced tools to help you
build things like weapons armor
harvesting tool all the way up to
frigging elevators for your eventual
skyscraper and huge siege weapons like
catapults and trebuchets yeah like I
said this was an early access for a long
time and it started up as a game that
seemingly everyone hated but it's come
such a long way and the community seems
to be completely in love with
now it still feels like a game that has
some kinks and bugs in it for example I
hate the UI with a passion and I cannot
imagine playing this on a console even
though it is out on Xbox and ps4 as well
but it's kind of a thing where it's a
game that's so massive and ambitious
that you can kind of forgive all that I
was caught off-guard initially because I
when I first got into it I wasn't seeing
anything any indicators that told me
what I could pick up yeah which is what
I'm used to instead of like a lighter
survival games until I realize that
almost everything I could see was up for
grabs so I would have to be collecting
the grass for like plant fibers and from
the bushes that was coming across
picking up rocks and sticks off the
ground like to get started and the
crafting tree is intense
so you can play this game either online
on a server filled with people or
offline by yourself when it comes to
online you can play on PvP servers where
anything goes or purely PvE servers you
know what it kind of feels a little bit
like wrath of the wild it it has the
Zelda style biomes and it's taken a leaf
out of the walls a book and you can
climb on any sort of madness surface
there are dungeons terrain there's a
religion system where you can worship a
deity
there are huge wall bosses that you can
apparently take down there's a cooking
system as a die system so one other
thing Internet exiles is that it was
infamous for its character creation
playing a survival game like this that
has like full nudity makes you feel
really vulnerable it don't make sense
for it it also makes it also makes sense
when you die and you lose all your [ __ ]
and you spawn like naked you feel what
you feel naked you feel like helpless
I honestly think if I only had time to
play one use falling down PC like this
year probably be Conan exiled
okay well some completely different
games fee this week do let us know which
one of these four games grabs your
interest this week or if there's a brand
new game that you had a look at that we
may have missed you can let us know on
our Twitter accounts I'm at Jessa
McDonald I'm at it's been trying and do
remember we will be back next week with
full brand new games but do let us know
if there's anything we should keep an
eye on in the meantime we'll see them
[Music]
[Music]